Speaker 1: A bunch of people have asked
me to comment about an article written by
CNN's Brian Stelter yesterday. And Stelter
is not a guy that I particularly follow,
but sometimes he says interesting things. And I
think that this is really an interesting article.
The idea here of what Brian Stelter is arguing is
that these new unhinged appearances and interviews
and rallies that Donald Trump is doing are a
sign of some kind of big storm brewing. Again,
that there's multiple factors here and that there
could be some kind of perfect storm, in a sense,
between Trump and Trump's followers in the
Republican Party and other just opportunists
in the Republican Party. Let's take a look at
a little bit of the article. Stelter writes,
I watched Donald Trump's entire interview with
one American news propagandist, Dan Balz. And
the quote that stood out the most is, our country
will not survive this. Trump was in the middle of
a fact free rant about vicious Democrats cheating
on elections when he said they're destroying our
country. Our country will not survive this.
Our country will not survive. Then he sniffed
and shifted to immigration, saying, look where
they're coming from, clearly mimicking the
great replacement theory that Tucker Carlson has
been mainlining into homes across the country.
These are all signs of the gathering storm,
Trump's incessant lies about the last election.
Biden didn't get any one million votes. There's
no way pose obvious threats to future elections.
The so-called Stop the Steele movement is racing
forward, ignoring the Arizona audit humiliation.
Most of us can feel the instability in the air the
same way a forecaster can feel a storm coming on.
News outlets need to be providing storm warnings,
but some are ignoring the threat. That's what. OK,
so he talks about his opening essay. He points
out. So so far, this is pretty good. Stelter
also points out that the right wing media, with
few exceptions, is a safe space for the big lie.
That's according to Timothy Snyder.
That's absolutely true. There has not been
a real concerted effort other than the minimum
needed to avoid legal problems to say Biden won.
That's it, all of this other stuff is not true
stuff about voting machines, stuff about bamboo
fibers and barbecue sauces and various dressings
on on ballots and the ballots being cured or
sauteed or smoked. You know, I'm exaggerating,
but none of this stuff is even there's no evidence
for any of this stuff going on to talk about.
Does Brian Stelter, Liz Cheney says many of her
colleagues in the Republican Party privately
agree with her, privately agree with her that
this election lies. Stuff just looks
very bad for Republicans. The idea being
these Republicans are going along with this stuff,
even though they don't believe it at all. And then
the big picture, according to Stelter, is that
democracy is in the midst of a grave recession
and points to Hungary, Poland and Venezuela,
countries that are no longer really democratic,
although they purportedly hold elections.
So I think that there's there's a you know,
I don't find smelter's writing to be particularly
compelling and I don't find his commentaries to
be particularly interesting. But I do think that
he's pointing to some broader truth that can't be
denied, at least as a possibility. Trump himself
is a narcissist to the absolute highest degree.
The election loss hurt him in a way that a
non narcissist can barely understand. I've
been reading about it to try to understand
how Trump gets to this point where he does
the things he's been doing. But it's hard for
non narcissist to really understand what's going
on in Trump's brain. And in addition, the idea of
people not paying attention to Trump is very, very
scary to him as a narcissist. That's Trump. On the
follower side, you have really low information,
radicalized trumpet's that are, in a sense
enamored with Trump as this narcissistic
egomaniac. I don't think we're exaggerating if
we say many of them are willing to die, would be
willing to die for Trump, would be not that that's
going to be a situation that presents itself for
ninety nine point nine nine nine percent of them.
Although, I mean, you know, look at January 6th,
it's not it's not merely hyperbolic or theoretical
to say a Trump might die for Trump in some sense.
So you put all of this together and then you
combine it with a Republican Party that even
if we grant Adam Kinzinger has said it, Liz Cheney
has said it, a couple of them have said privately,
almost nobody agrees with this stuff. Like
Kinzinger, I think said there's a couple people
in my mind. I'm thinking he was talking about
Marjorie Taylor Greene or whoever else. If they
are right, what that means is it's not that we
say, well, at least the Republican Party is sane
because behind the scenes, they don't believe the
stuff. No, no, no, no. They're the worst class of
political opportunists we can imagine because
behind the scenes, they don't believe it. And
yet they allow all of this stuff to continue. And
in some cases, they actually signal boost it and
help it continue. That combination narcissistic
Trump enamored egomaniac, low information,
Trump supporters who will do whatever he says
and fall for whatever. And then a Republican
Party that whatever they believe privately isn't
getting in the way of what Donald Trump is doing.
That is a very disturbing situation. And you could
see circumstances in which, if they do well in 22,
if they take the house, they're almost certainly
impeaching Joe Biden. Without question. It won't
they won't get convicted in the Senate, but almost
certainly and it may be the exact boost to what we
are hoping is a dying movement in Trump ism. Doing
well in 22 could be the exact type of boost that
will make 23 to 25 the pier that that legislative
session crazier than even what was going on under
Obama when day 63, what was it? Sixty four,
sixty three times voted to eliminate Obamacare
when they had the House and Obama was president,
we said, what a waste of time. This is crazy.
That will be nothing compared to what we will see
from January of twenty three to January of 2005
if they take the house partially because of what
they'll do, but partially because of the energy
boost it will give to people like Trump and others
who will be thinking about twenty twenty four. So
smelter's pretty spot on here. I don't know that I
would tell the story the way he tells it. I think
I would look at maybe some other indicators, but
there very well may be a storm brewing. And these
are the exact worst people that we would want
running the weather satellites, so to speak, when
that storm is brewing. Agree with me, disagree
with me. Let me know. You can find me on Twitter
at David Pakman. Remember, The David Pakman Show
is primarily made possible by people like you,
people who sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom, we
do a Daily Show every day just for our members.
The bonus show. You can get instant access
by signing up on the website and you can use
the coupon code dystopian rally today to get
a huge discount. What am I talking about?